okay hello good morning thanks for
coming my name is Jun I'm from IAS
they're all going to talk about my joint
work with Petter about the class that we
call Lorenz Ian polynomials so I'm
relative ly a newcomer to the field my
initial training is in algebraic
geometry so naturally I rarely had an
opportunity to think about polynomials I
mean I'll try Keanu to think of a lot of
different things but usually they don't
think about that specific class of
polynomials but I always loved
polynomials and I really learned a lot
about polynomials by working with
pattern and I truly enjoyed the process
it's my first experience of doing sort
of a hand-to-hand combat with specific
class of polynomials and I hope you will
enjoy thinking about this class too
so if you think this topic is
interesting you should also attend the
pop-up Cynthia on today and quick quiz
talk tomorrow because they were going to
talk about closely related topics let me
just very briefly tell you where I'm
coming from
Eldridge geometers think about
projective varieties so let's say I have
a projective variety Y inside some space
P to the N and in this situation you can
compute the volume of Y using the
distinguished metric on P to the N so
you can compute the volume of this
projective variety Y but of course it's
not an interesting variant it depends on
how you embedded your Y into the
projective space so you can really write
it like volume of the specific embedding
of Y into projective space and one of
the great things that geometers have
noticed it was that when you want to
study the intrinsic geometry of Y and of
course there will be many many different
ways of putting Y inside the projective
space and if you collect a set of all
possible different embeddings then a
very useful and beautiful structure
arises and this is this set of all
possible different embeddings what we
call the ample cone
there's a some open convex cone inside a
some finite dimensional real vector
space and we say that this convex cone
essentially because we can add or
multiply two different embeddings
because if you have one embedding into
the projective space and another
embedding into the projective space you
can now use the fact that the product of
projective spaces can be somehow
naturally embedded in a larger
projective space to add two different
projective embeddings of Y to get
another projective embedding so now if
you consider this totality of possible
projective embeddings this process of
computing the volume of Y becomes a
function so for every point in here in
the ample kkona by you have a projective
embedding and you can compute the volume
of Y with respect to that embedding and
the Hodge theory
apply tells you that this volume
function has very special properties
particularly says that
this volume function is log concave on
that amp account why
so that's a very beautiful fact but it
poses certain natural questions
especially naturally from the point of
view of a modern algebraic geometry so
many a large chunk of modern algebraic
geometry is devoted to the study of
these different embeddings when you take
the embeddings near to the boundary of
the ample cone where the limit will no
longer be ample and then associated to
such process there will be lots of lots
of different than intricate geometry of
why so it essentially produces a map
from Y to some other thing which need
not be an embedding so it's interesting
to think about what happens to this
process of taking volume when you take
your reference measure near the limit
so that's how it came
to the notion of what we now call
Laurentian polynomials
and you can prove a lot about this class
that are going to shortly define but one
thing that is most fascinating to me is
that it quite natural the links to
different notions of convexity so
there's a usual and the obvious notion
of continuous convexity and there is a
a speed analog of notion of convexity
under the name of discrete convex
analysis and the Lorentzian polynomials
I smoothly links these two notions so
what am I talking about
so suppose you have a polynomial in many
variables maybe it has real coefficients
and you can view it as a function that
you can view it as it has a function in
two different ways of course you can you
can view it in the usual way say your
polynomial is f and if you have n
variables then you can viewed as a
function from all and to all so and
where you just evaluate points the
evaluations of F will be values of this
function but you can also view it as a
function
domain is discrete and to the end they
are where the function is almost
everywhere zero and where it's nonzero
it simply takes coefficients
where you identify the domain as a set
of all possible monomials and I suppose
everyone who loves polynomial I mean
have wondered how these two functions
are related to each other and in the
theory of lawrencium polynomials the
notion of convexity in this sense and
that sense are very tightly glued to
each other in the sense that I'm going
to tell you soon
so let me start defining this class so
everything I'm going to say is
essentially a multivariate calculus
where all the homeworks I did in
multivariate calculus class aside I did
it for today so let's let's let's start
from introducing some symbols so so H DN
that I mean the set of all degree D
homogeneous polynomials and variables
with coefficients in our so that's a
finite dimensional vector space over the
real numbers and I'll start from the
case when D equals two so quadratic
forms there in the space of all
quadrille quadratic forms are going to
define an open subset that I'll going to
not write by L not so this not is there
to express the fact that it's an open
subset it's a set of all quadratic forms
but positive coefficients
by that I mean all the coefficients are
positive
not just none negative I also require
that the drafting booms have
currency and signature
which I mean plus minus minus minus
minus in particular this quadratic form
is non-singular so that's L not of a -
end
well not of a dn4 deed larger than two
as a set of all homogeneous polynomials
of VD in n variables with a property
that the partial derivative with respect
to the ID variable where I is one of
your N variables of F belongs to L not
of a t minus 1 to the N all I
and this is clearly an open subset of HD
to the end because you can perturb these
conditions in a little bit and still
stay in the same set and this open set
is what I call the setup strictly
Laurentian
it looks like a recursive definition but
I mean there's nothing really much to it
so how do you check that your F is in
this set well you have to check that
every partial derivatives in the same
set for one less degree but how do you
check that you again compute partial
derivatives until you get the quadratic
form so this condition simply means that
all the coefficients of your homogeneous
polynomial have post positive
coefficients and all the quadratic poems
that you can get by taking repeated
partial derivatives is Lorentz Ian
have you singled out the preparation
yeah because I'm trying to model this
situation so that's my heart Riemann
relation the heart in Dec theorem for
surfaces so that's that was another
thing that was very interesting while
carrying out this project so I and keep
saying that all I'm saying is a
multivariate calculus but I think it's
somewhat tricky I mean it was at times
quite tricky to carry out this exercises
in calculus but I always had this
picture in mind and somehow having this
picture tells me what to do next
and somehow the calculus trick works
beautifully if you have a right
motivation so this is surfaces where two
is the dimension of your variety and I'm
looking at the D dimensional varieties
and n reference and performs and trying
to play a little game without actually
doing the geometry
and first I want to what I want to
understand is the closure of L not en
and by definition this is what I call
the set of Lorenz Ian polynomials this
is what I get as limit of volume
polynomials in a sense I want
I like picturing this set inside the
projective space so let's take the
projective space of this hdn and then
I'm going to have a image of this open
subset of strictly lawrencium
polynomials some open subset
and in fact this open subset is
contractible
and what I am interested in is what kind
of polynomials you get in the boundary
of this open subset
so there are some obvious conditions
that anything in the boundary should
satisfy everything in the interior has
positive coefficient so anything in the
boundary should have non-negative
coefficients and everything in the
interior has associated quadratic forms
which is Laurentian so if there's a
limit of such things then at the limit
your quadratic forms should have at most
one positive eigenvalue so that's the
condition but they're interesting what
makes things interesting is that this is
not all so there's a Down example of a
cubic form so maybe a my F has two
variables that we want the cube and W to
to the cube and well it has all the
non-negative coefficients and partial
derivatives are very nice certainly they
have non-negative coefficients and have
at most one positive eigen value and
these two clearly belongs to the closure
of L not to end well it's not too hard
to convince yourself that F itself is
not in the closure so F is somewhere
here
you cannot find you cannot express f as
a limit of strictly the valencian
polynomials
this is where discrete convex analysis
first comes in it will keep coming in
but this is the first place so let me
you a little bit about story there's a
very nice book written by Marotta with
the same title
so I'm not going to fully justify why
what I'm writing here is the crack
discrete analogue of the convexity but
at least I'll try to
make some sense of out of it so there's
a definition suppose you have a subset
of something like n to the N and you
want to say whether such J is complex or
not of course clearly you want J to be
the set of all integral points in of
this convex hull but the point of the
discrete convex analysis is that this is
not enough so you have to impose
stronger conditions and one condition
that turns out to work out beautifully
is this notion of M convexity and you
say that this J is M come back see if
for any two elements alpha and beta and
J and any index I this is one of the
coordinates
if I coordinate up alpha is larger than
the ice coordinate of beta
and you want the property that there is
a another index J in n with a property
that the J's coordinate of alpha is
smaller than the J's coordinate of beta
and you want alpha minus CI + ej to be
in my set J where E is the standard unit
vector in n to the N and also beta minus
e j + e i
so if you know mate or a theory you will
see the symmetric exchange axiom here so
what is required here is that if you
look at say ice direction and the J's
direction and if you have some point
alpha here with ice coordinate is larger
than the ice coordinate the beta then
the condition is that you should always
be able to find another direction so
that if you move beta toward alpha so by
subtracting J and adding I and if you
move alpha word beta then these two
points should be also in the set J so
that's the convexity condition that we
are requiring
the typical example is when you have a
mate right and if you're J is a set of
all bases that's a subset of n to the N
so I view each one of the bases which is
a subset of n as a zero one vector then
this is M convex agreed this M stands
for make sure you can think of it as a
multi set I know of a [ __ ] also L
convexity let's not go there in a sense
yes but let's not yeah let's not go
there
okay so so let me give you my second
definition
of the symbol mdn so this will be game
be the set of polynomials homogeneous
degree D polynomials in n variables and
it's the set of all forms the support of
F by which I mean the set of all
monomials that appear in the expression
for F viewed as a subset of n to the N
is M contacts
and when the equals to are going to
define l2n in the set of all quadratic
forms non-negative coefficients
have at most one positive I can't
believe this is the set I mentioned
before
for general D
I'm going to define LDN to be the set of
homogeneous polynomial whose support is
M comebacks and in addition to that you
want every one of the partial
derivatives to be in the LT the D minus
1 TN
so it's actually not hard to show that
if F has support which is M convex every
one of partial derivatives necessarily
have the support which is M convex so
here again the real condition in
addition to M convexity is simply that
all the quadratics you get by taking
partial derivatives
it's non-negative coefficients and have
at most one pacified
yes the income tax the same thing as
being the set of London personnel it is
essentially equivalent to being a set of
integral points in what people call
generalized holy Metroid's so it's a
pair of submodular functions not just
one John system is a little bit more
general
so John system if I remember correctly
need not be need not have that property
that it's a set of all integral points
of its come back soon
what geniuses employ one of the basic
observation is that this is equal to the
set of lawrencium polynomials as I have
defined earlier so this red close
compact thing is in fact
identical to the object that I would
write like this but if you look at just
that how its defined it's not even clear
why this thing is closed because I mean
this set is not closed or anything well
it turns out that this set is a closed
set so it's a compact and in fact the
contractable subset of the projective
space
space it has contractable interior
which is not the end so I so this is
very a pole like object
and you can write it as a disjoint union
of setup Laurentian polynomials
let's support Jay
so this pattern is very interesting so
another thing is that if you write the
set according to the support then notice
that this set LJ is non empty
if and only if jsm comebacks
so this disjoint union is actually over
all em comeback subsets of the these
discrete simplex in and variables
and each one of these pieces
so this patch that little patch that you
see in the boundary as contractable well
actually it's a deformation retracts
distinguished point in it so I'm going
to talk about this distinguished point
later it's again like a somewhat like a
pole like object
and the picture is especially pleasant
if you take a linear section of this set
where you only consider multiplying
polynomials
so you don't you want only scary terms
and then what it says is that this
collection the set of all the multi upon
lawrencium polynomials that's again
compact and contractable and this time
they express it as a disjoint union of
actually all matrix rank d may trade
on n elements and for any such thing the
corresponding patch is non empty and
contractable
so this is roughly the picture so I have
as open setup strictly lawrencium
polynomials and if you think about the
definition it's very like a smooth and
analytic definition and there's like no
place for discrete things to then but
this is another nice example of the
intuition that we are sharing that if
you take the limit then things tend to
become discrete we have a smooth and
contractible more like thing the closure
it's still bowl-like but the very
beautiful discrete pattern appears is
that so it's somewhat like a soccer ball
but it's much much more intricate so
it's covered by all these little ball
like pieces
and each piece is labeled by and in fact
it has distinguished points
eventually by May torts label by
Metroid's or M comeback sets this little
pieces
I highly doubt well I don't know let's
see yeah and the beautiful thing is that
you actually see all the make toys
so in particularly it does not
discriminate am a Troy by well this is
representable where certain fields or
not over certain feels its it just sees
all of them so in this in this fall you
see like all your favorite configuration
like final configuration and Papas
configuration or all your favorite
graphs like k4 k5 Patterson of course
you have to have matching N and D but
you can arrange that just by adding
loops and colors so you see all of your
favorite objects and all the rich
history and just as the single pictures
know so that was very satisfying but
what is actually nice about this class
lorenzi employee know meals is that it's
equivalent to so many other concepts
which are apparently more strong
the one of them
as this notion introduced by perverts
so we say that a polynomial with
non-negative coefficients say in n
variables it's strongly low concave
for every alpha in n to the N
the alphas partial derivative of F is
either identically zero or log concave
on the positive Orton
I think I also hit like the condition
was for entire functions yes yes so
maybe it's not let's just restrict to
polynomials for now
and another basic observation is that
these conditions are equivalent
homogeneous polynomials non-negative
coefficients
and so when I have n variables I'll just
write W for the collection of one is
rapid Lorentzian
- is Efes
it's wrong a local cave
back it's equivalent to another notion
that since I will introduce shortly
so I don't think any of the implication
is entirely trivial this is a one place
that I
I'm pretty amazing that how this little
tricks are can be found by going back to
the algebraic geometric intuition so
saying that f is strongly low concave
something like this is to an algebraic
geometers
saying something like your variety wise
I despise [ __ ] manipulation why is it
equivalent to being lawrencium because
this is essentially a condition on the
quadratics which is conditioned on the
surfaces but like basic intuition shared
by most algebraic geometers is that any
college coalition that you make on a
projective variety is that all the
essence is contained in the in the
middle in the middle of the kamala G in
the middle degree so if you're if you're
looking at the hot riemann relations in
degree one you're right he may have very
high dimension but they're in degree one
all the information should come from the
case of surfaces and that that's what
that's what's happening here
and once the three are equivalent but I
mean but you have to use like filled up
real puja series yeah yeah but that's
just tarski because your field is
probably real closed and and it turns
out that these are all like a person
with the sentences in fact so you don't
really have to mention love or anything
yeah so if you're using a reasonable
filled with quantifier elimination you
expect one minus replacing matrons by
metroid subdivisions right I'll tell you
so
and this this equivalence is very useful
because certain properties of this form
of these polynomials are not so clear in
one description but nearly trivially in
other description for example the
product of two strongly local k
polynomials is supposed to be strongly
low concave and sounds like an exercise
but it's actually I think it's very
tricky it's almost trivial that this
product of lawrencium polynomials is
ruined and so on
but the real beauty of this thing is
that this entire framework extends from
comeback sets to convex functions so so
far I have been talking about convex
sets discrete comeback sets of course
they any true convex analysis should
talk about convex functions and not just
comeback sets and people do this so if
you have a say let's say you have a sum
function we find on n to the end and its
value takes values in R and it can be
infinite somewhere and whenever you have
such a function you say that we knew has
an effective domain which is the set of
all the alphas
we're new in spy night and I'm going to
introduce a notion which you can also
find it in Metis book which makes it
clear that the affective domain of any
convex function is convex
so the definition looks nearly identical
you say that such discrete function is
I'm come back safe for any two points
alpha and beta in the affective domain
of you and for any I on index I in n
where ice coordinate of alpha is larger
than the ice coordinator beta you want
to have an index J where J is coordinate
of alpha is smaller than the J's
coordinator beta so that the sum of the
values of the functions that alpha and
beta should be at least as large as new
alpha minus CI + ej + nu of a beta minus
EJ so that's the notion of convexity you
want in this context
of course the most basic example of such
function
comes from convex sets suppose you have
an M convex set in the function new say
J defined by saying that its value is
either zero or infinite depending on
whether alpha is in J where alpha is not
in J
and another example for tropical
geometers called tropical linear spaces
there's another name for valuated
metroid
which is according to the usual
convention which is M concave functions
but you can take - whenever
the observation in this context is that
if you have any such discrete function
nu which is defined on n to the N takes
values on all to the infinite and these
conditions are equivalent versus the
convexity of Nu
and the second is the lawrencium
property of partition function of you so
to speak so I'm going to define a
polynomial in n variables sense and it
depends on a parameter Q so it's a
family of polynomials it's a sum of sum
over all the points in the affective
domain of U and some n corresponding to
alpha is Q to the new alpha and you have
the corresponding monomial W alpha
normalize by alpha factorial
the statement is that this polynomial is
ruined
for all she was in the range 0 & 1
in the third statement which all not
going to make very precise but I'll say
it is that there is a Lorentzian
polynomial
over one of Byrnes favorite known
Archimedean field kay let's say just a
field of real pooja series with rational
exponents so on whose optical ization
so if your valuation on K has rationals
then you have to place this out by that
so in in a sense that discrete convex
analysis is exactly the tropical ization
of the theory of Lorenz Ian polynomials
but even disregarding this third
statement that I haven't actually made
precise the classical part tells you
some non-trivial statements so for
example if your new is one of these guys
the function of associated two sets then
if the value of new is either zero or
infinite then this polynomial has
nothing to do with Q so you see that J
and n to the N is M comebacks if and
only if
it's generating function so sum over all
the monomials
no more wise no y'all silver chain
and also things like you can plug in
specific cue so for example if write
arbitrary homogeneous polynomial using
the lowest coefficient C alpha and you
know that it's lawrencium this function
ending alpha to the log of normalized
coefficient is M convex and concave so
I've replaced convex by concave because
I'm using natural logarithms here and E
is larger than 1 so I'm putting - I know
and you can play a lot of fun games and
for example you can prove analog of the
theorem of Portia and Brandon that you
are probably familiar with so they have
a characterization of linear operators
that preserve stability and the
Lorentzian analog of that exactly work
in the same way and in particular any
one of your favorite operators that
transforms polynomials into another
polynomials probably preserve dimension
polynomials too so one consequence of
our
renze an analogue aperture Brandon tells
you that any linear operator between
bounded degree polynomials that preserve
homogeneous homogeneity I mean it
doesn't have to preserve function that
is homogeneous of some degree and
preserves able polynomials and preserve
polynomials with non-negative
coefficients then in automatically
preserve lawrencium polynomials so it's
quite likely that one of your favorite
linear operators like a part of
symmetrization or like that
which is only two guys okay and the
possible convex combination of them and
you get this philosophy my my my guess
would be that this implies alexander
eventual type inequality but not the
other way around but I'm not 100%
convinced you think you try just see in
the quality which you can deduce from
that way but converse combination I
think yeah baby because essentially all
of this is like a secretly like a
condition on quadratic so it's really
yeah yeah yeah which is Hodgman deck
theorem to us
okay so let me let me let me just close
it up just by showing you this picture
one more time I have a compact
contractor will set I take the closure I
see certain patterns in there limit and
this set of lawrencium polynomials like
contains lots of familiar objects like
it has a large open set that will not
open its set of stable polynomials and
any stable polynomial is automatically
Laurentian but not the other way around
and it it contains all these volume
polynomials
well maybe convex bodies say
or of projective varieties they are all
Orencia
I don't think algebraic geometers were
aware that the volume polynomials of any
projected variety has n come back
support it's a very geometric assertion
in concrete situations and and it that's
it has some sporadic interesting members
so you can show that something called
the multivariate polynomial of may point
it's Lorentzian and you can use it to
prove something like very concrete and
classical conjectures like mesas
conjecture and independent sets and you
can prove something like the
multivariate
characteristic polynomial M matrices
it's a class of matrices where all the
principal minors are positive they are
all Orencia
the lawrencium property of this implies
a theorem upholds which is the case of
one variable so to speak and it has a
very interesting likeable like patch
that I have mentioned before and I
suppose there are so many other
interesting specific combinatorial
polynomials living in this domain and of
course to a combinatorial is most of the
interesting population will live on the
boundary just a little bit like
Australia so most of them will be here
so so we need to explore a little bit
more another nice connection is that if
you tropical eyes the whole picture well
say if you work with multiplying
polynomials then you get exactly what
tropical geometers called the dress Ian
it's one of the easiest kind of examples
that geometers called moduli spaces
that's a beautiful symmetry so and it's
it's a I mean technically speaking it's
just a specific kind of rational
polyhedral fan and the smallest
non-trivial example is a simply a fan
over Patterson graph so there is another
very unexpected discrete strict
structure appearing here there's a hole
over this living inside all to the 10
some linearity space and of course if
you follow non multiplying polynomials
or if you go higher degree so this is
the case when T equals 2 and N equals 5
you get something like this but far-far
intricate structure but it's still a
rational polyhedral fan
and you can explore going back and forth
using bridges like this I'll stop there
[Applause]
so I have a question about the
motivation on projective varieties so
typically there is no choice of
coordinate something about the cubic
surface so the volume pollen or
polynomial several variables but then
all note of any context see it depends
on a choice of coordinates can you
comment so not choose coordinates so
here's what's happening so so I always
have my parameters DNN that's my
dimension of variety what is this end so
I have a ample cone it's a it's a sum
cone it may have it may be crazy with
scone and what I'm doing is I pick end
points
if you want to be really canonical and
if your amplicon turns out to be
polyhedral maybe I take extreme arrays
and the point of all this analysis is
what happens if i take this reference
measures to the limit so the volume
polynomial in this context will be h1 if
i have an ample divisors then your
volume polynomial in n variables is
simply the self-intersection product of
this linear combination and the question
is what happens if you drag each one of
their eyes to the boundary
so that's the answer to the support
question I mean that's yes yes yes yes
yeah so if you have NF divisors then
their intersection pattern should be
always M convex so in particular
intersecting local should be the
integral points of a certain poet ah and
that positive is not arbitrary polytop
because this M convex is very special so
every edges is in E I minus EJ direction
so it's it's like a I think that that's
the current discrete convex analysis
like a type a convex analysis and that
there there there may be that other
I would what will happen that was one of
the questions which I was thinking if
you go to fractional derivatives I'm
afraid I don't know if you may click
continuously ocean extend fractional
deities because my motivation when I was
learning then was professional in
Commerce City would you go which is like
we're both about to get generalized
Newton and quality same yeah the
question the natural sink was which
ended I don't know how to extend to all
points in the Newton Polito but what
will happen there I have nothing
intelligent thing to say I don't know
what fraction of their tips I'm sorry
that's one more question one of the
special points of each matrix Travis
oh that's just yeah that's a generating
function it's just a basis and then the
point what makes this structure nice is
that there is a very large semi group
action that contracts everything to this
distinguished point that's how I know it
all deformation retracts to that point
and and what is the semi group I mean it
comes from this observation that yeah
basically anything that preserves stable
polynomials automatically preserve for
instance
[Applause]